ok here we go alright well welcome back
in thank you do me a solid I have some
technical difficulties and I'll you know
and then also like I was supposed to
have you on like a week ago that we
missed a call I don't know what's going
on but here we are right now
happy July 4th weekend and how how was
it for you how are you how you doing it
was a weird one
you know because of all just the
craziness of the times yeah I agree
and you're seeing like a lot of like
memes and post against the celebration
of the day yeah it's like it's like the
lamest birthday ever you know for for a
country like an end because of Kogut
like everybody like I spoke to a friend
and he was desperate to Dean and he said
he was out that day and there was nobody
on the street yeah you know so then but
I ended up after like taking a long time
to just get out the house ended up going
to like a friend's like a apartment
rooftop in West Hollywood and that was
cool like everybody in the building a
lot but not everybody but a bunch of
people in the building went up there as
a pool is a jacuzzi
and everybody was in their separate
groups and there but they shared the
grill they [ __ ] they played music and it
was like late evening and you can see
all of like everywhere from Wilshire all
the way down to like several other
beaches they had like a new of LA
just a beautiful display of illegal
fireworks would you have but like I
noticed like would it have been a good
party in regular circumstances like if
you were gone if you gone to this party
and there was no Kofi going on would you
have been like oh we had her this was
the bomb for the July party are you
trying to say like in airplane food
terms because airplane food first class
is good when you're on a plane and they
said your first class airplane food
you're like oh this is delicious
gotcha you took a girl on a date and the
restaurant you took her to it was
serving her first class airplane food
spitting well yeah so you're asking me
well I just know it was a really good
accidental good time because it's not
like he invited me to a party like him
and two friends were on the roof and
then people from there are other
apartments then and their true friends
were on the roof and then another people
and their two friends on the roof and
something were girls or some of them are
guys someone ever made bikinis someone
or the hot tub somewhere in the pool
then music was playing say seemed like
somebody planned a party but it was a
sigh people had no way to go in the
building says let me just go on a roof
right in everybody felt like people who
could just get along and hang I wore my
mask and you know talk to people ran
into people I didn't expect to run into
and just - well that's good so you
saying it would have been a whack party
if you know it's funny I was talking to
do you know David Lucas and he was
telling me how he went down to the
American comedy club and he was like me
he was like oh man it's great - people
are starving for entertainment and that
just made me think I was like oh so a
lot of people who aren't that funny when
economy starts up are gonna think they
really funny because the crowds are
gonna be like oh so there's like there's
no expectation of like where we were
when this happened like I think comedy
was at a high level I think that you
know we were because of like social
event social things happening it
really changed the approach of comedy
but now we've been set back so now just
any old thing people gonna be like oh
it's so good to make me laugh and then
so it's gonna be good we got set back
like five years again I talked about
David I'm just saying in general when
people come back for to do comedy I'm
glad you cleared it out sound like your
song no no no I'm not right now I'm not
talking about David
but everybody's gonna be rusty comics
are gonna be rusty audiences are gonna
be rusty but there's gonna be a
universal rustiness like when people I
fully go back to work they're gonna be
rusty so when they come to a comedy club
I think everybody's standard it's just
gonna be lower all over the world like
right now European soccer started back
up I'm watching games without a crowd no
audience they're usually like 40 to
60,000 people in packed stadiums singing
and chanting as the game goes on I'm
just watching players yell at each other
right now
yeah it's different not so much it's
different but I miss it so much
I'm not complaining right you know my
team is doing good okay I'm waiting for
the NBA to come back for that I wonder
how that's gonna be like I did gonna
hear people like it's almost a
completely different experience it's
almost like watching and like some dudes
play at a park and you watch another
smack talk and I'm it might be a whole
other level of a game playing like
experience fur as a viewing person right
as a viewer as a fan are you going
Sneaky's lake I want to go back to
something that you were said about the
July 4th and how because I have I've
seen on I saw something on Instagram
where somebody was like you know [ __ ]
this holiday we should be worried about
something else you know like like
Brianna Taylor keeps coming up you know
and something that's been bothering me
is that I think people are more about
the noise than they are about the cause
itself and once the noise starts to go
away you know people don't look at these
things in the same way that they did
when it was like mob mentality and it's
a shame because
there's still a lot of work to be done
since the George Floyd killing and
everything that has happened up to this
point right now I'm start do you get a
sense that people just to be put it
bluntly don't care about it as much as
they did say a month ago there's less
action but that people are still
protesting there's still protest then
you know like you know one thing that's
keeping it alive here's a funny
he's a funny bad thing a funny bad thing
is keeping two George Floyd and the
black lives matter movement going I
don't want to destroy my minute discuss
something about black last man taught
you well something that's keeping a
movement going is like you know you know
occasionally I repost it they haven't
arrested the killers of Brianna Taylor
right so I only post that other people
do too but every time you like dozing
off at the wheel you know and you wake
up you wake up to the video of the cops
murdering someone else and this doesn't
have to be like a new murder it's just
like the McClain murder that they kept
digging up these videos yeah yeah my 18
mm just to like spike up them the
movement like yeah don't forget this was
happening they did it again not today
but last year around this time they did
it again and then everybody's a art so
we gotta get these so there's this like
so many tapes out there it's like all
these murder sex tapes are dropping yeah
yeah the movement back up I saw um
Andrew Schultz had this really funny
video on his Instagram it's like you
could tell you know it was a scripted
thing too he and it was well done you
know just the things oh me too cuz cuz
he was hitting some points that made me
go damn good job like just the way he
did it it wasn't just some free-flowing
talk it was like he was hitting points
like a news program you know and one and
one of the things he was talking about
and that was about like you know hey
like all the white celebrities and stuff
it's like do you you know it's enough
you're not
you're not really helping for your
brownie points you're trying to get you
know and like I remember I've seen a
video of like a bunch of white people
going we renounce our white privilege
you know and which is literally the most
white privilege thing you could possibly
do is to give up your white pearly you
know but but I liken it to like as much
as you want but you you just saying it
yeah that's what I mean but like but
this is my point about and my analogy to
Ford is like I was watching the Jeffrey
Epstein documentary have you seen that
yeah yeah yes she is wild man this Wow
just to know that he was filming like he
had cameras and other and he might have
something like for sure he was murdered
by people with power and influence
because they probably found the tapes
were burned that they probably tortured
him in jail where the tapes they got to
tapes and they got rid of his ass but
anyways in the documentary there was a
guy that worked at the island you know
and you know you they show him a lot cuz
he's like well you know I didn't know
what was going on and then he says you
know once I you know I figured out what
was going on and I saw this and I quit
you know he says you know I quit and in
my mind I go so [ __ ] what you quit
like you quitting did nothing to help
those girls like you quitting because
the real power it is people above that
guys paygrade that's how I feel about
white celebrities and all these white
people who are like I renounce my white
privilege who cares the white people
that are most important are the ones
that make the real decisions people in
the government people their own
corporations you know I need Warren
Buffett to come out and be like black
lives matter
I need a you know the guy the the the
Amazon guy who now is the richest guy in
the world I need him to like you know
could a give a billion dollars to the
black lives I just think that the people
that really meant that these people that
are doing all this stuff for social
media credit and you know they feel
pressured I don't care what they have to
say thank you for saying it thank you
for being a part of the movement
but it's not the thing that's gonna help
take make any change the change has to
come from like I say the people that
really have power and influence and I
don't hear those people saying [ __ ] I
mean I don't believe it like saying that
you renounce your white privilege is a
waste of white privilege you use the
white privilege to help people of color
gain an equal amount of civility so
don't give something up or renounce it
you can admit it and accept it and then
like how can we use this because there's
people who are gonna listen to us that
like it's so it is kind of self-serving
say I renounce you know you eat like
like at least think about it
don't say I renounce all right I'm gonna
use my white privilege I obviously have
this to do better for all mankind
we all have privileges like we live in
America so we can make a living like I'm
not gonna renounce the money I make or
you but if you want to use some of the
money you make to send it to less
fortunate people to help them out that's
what you do that's what they have those
commercials for so don't write don't in
this case renounce anything vow to use
it for like embrace it yeah and invoke
the betterment of all mankind and I
think preaching to the choir doesn't
help either I just don't think that that
you know you know you you know it's just
like the award shows when they're like
you know there are they're up there and
they they're bashing Trump and they're
saying all this stuff as if as if the 65
million people there voted for Trump are
watching this program now they're not
they turned it off the moment you
started this and they're like well I
guess I'm not gonna see my favorite
movie wins so let me go watch something
else I gotta flip over to Fox News so
it's like you're not helping by
preaching to the choir so I just I don't
know I just sometimes you know and I
don't want to think the worst of people
like I mean there are I think that there
are a lot of people who are non
minorities just you know white people
and people that are not black you know
that who are like now going oh man this
actually is worse than I thought and
they don't know what to say and they
don't know what to do they don't know
how to react and the Twitter mob the
social media mob
kind of you know it's it's it's like a
tornado that's forcing people to move in
the direction that they don't want to
move but I do feel like a lot of people
have good intentions it's just I wish I
wish that these things were making some
real change you know there are some
changes being made come on now we got
the black national anthem which nobody
asked for to be played on we got this
anthem that nobody that is not what we
asked for we asked for the ending of
police brutality yeah but any [ __ ] is
a song yeah I know but I thought it was
maybe maybe on the positive side maybe
playing it during each game might get
some people attention that it normally
might not be like but still we still
want what we want which is what
everybody has a right yeah yeah just you
know just treat people better is what we
really just want you know but it's like
I don't know man
III think that the only thing that moves
the moves the needle in this country is
money and you know if we really want to
make a difference it's a it's like if
you want mcdonald's corporation to say
do something positive the way to do that
is like if we convinced everyone in
america to go don't even Donnell's for a
week and see what happens you know like
once you start once it starts affecting
the bottom line that's when things
change in this country it's never about
social issues man if you go back to
Jackie Robinson getting in baseball he
did get into baseball because they were
trying to help black people they wanted
to black dollars they saw the Negro
Leagues succeeding they were like well
how can we get all those people spending
money to come over here well let's grab
the players who are obviously better the
faster stronger better athletes I mean
and then and then we have more money in
our pockets so like it's like I it were
Donald sterling Donald sterling
he's been racist he's done racist things
and prejudiced things toward with his
build places he
these weird rental practices he was
accused of that and sued and and he's
been found guilty of that for the last
30 years the moment Pepsi coke and all
these people were like yeah we're gonna
pull out of the Staples Center because
of this guy that's what the NBA was like
whoa whoa whoa we're gonna window where
we gonna take care of this so I think
that the you know that's where we need
this movement to move towards is to use
our financial resources or use our
buying power to make a difference look
at looting looting and burning down one
store is not gonna make a difference if
all these people peaceful protesting if
they said we're not gonna shop at
Sephora that'll just make a difference
yeah yeah well we need like
people with great minds to organize a
protest in a way that it's not
necessarily marching anymore or people
who are down for the cause put
themselves at risk of Kovach we need
like plan and I really thought out plan
and some of that plan is happening like
I went to the Mart pour L'Amour park
which is a black neighborhood in Los
Angeles the other day and they have like
an Arts District and they have
restaurants black-owned
and bookstores and I took a friend of
mine and she's why she wanted to go buy
something black from the black
bookstores like online people have been
like point now black book businesses
right and they had social distance in
line outside the store it was up mostly
at that point that I was there white
people on the line yeah like lining up
to buy books from that black store so
that is something that was suggested
during the peak of you know what's
happened over the last few months where
a lot of black owned businesses were
suggested where people talk about
goodbye and I guess people are doing
that so and then you know so cuz when
that happens because me and you watch
the same video of the guy we said you do
it and you keep doing it until stores
and cooperations lose a lot of money and
then in turn to get the minority and the
black customer back will donate money to
the cause but the cause has to come up
with a plan to where we can and use
social media more instead of like
there's ways to protest like here's some
stories you can all buy but come up with
a list of stores and any one of us could
do is it is a list of stores with
everything that people get from Amazon
or just anywhere else
here are some black stores where you can
get it from you know what I mean yeah
and then so people can just pass the
link around and you know I think that's
a small thing I really do think that's a
small
thing in the ground London no no I know
I know but I'm talking about this let me
give you an example of what I'm talking
about right now FedEx the company FedEx
a guide the CEO of FedEx I believe he
owns 10% of the Washington Redskins and
there's a there's a movement now that's
getting a lot of traction now because
FedEx and a couple of other major
corporations are telling Dan Schneider
the owner of the Washington Redskins
that you need to change the name it so
it's incent and so that power like like
that's what I'm saying is like how could
I mean everything that's happened since
the day of the George Floyd's murder was
broadcast to our phones is working like
thing yes but I feel like but I agree
with you but I feel like the noise is
now lower so now you know you can hear
someone yelling but when the yelling
stops and that's to me is the mob
mentality when that stops what's left
because because there's a there's a
there's an attitude of like when people
first heard about say Brianna Taylor
there'd be like oh man this is
ridiculous I can't believe that just
happened then it's like oh my god oh my
god I think people that get into the
point now where they're gonna see those
posts now be like this still oh you
really I just think that's a natural
thing about how people don't care about
because you know how people are this way
I tell you how I know people this way
these are because of how they deal with
kovat wearing a mask is not for you
wearing a mask is for everyone else and
these people that are going wearing a
mask is stupid
I don't want to wear a mask only only
these type of people are dying that sort
of selfish attitude is how people also
feel about when it's time to make change
protesting when you see some injustice
at first it's like okay and then now
what and I just feel like it's waning
off and I and how do we spark the fire
again or keep it sustained where we can
really make a difference because some
police are gonna do some dumb [ __ ] and
then we're gonna get new videos right
you can count on that but you know
to give you hope there are things that
are changing like but it's not all the
things that we want but some things are
changing like well I get that listen
there's been so many murders I can't
remember the kid's name the violinist
kid that was killed by a chokehold and
injected with ketamine in Aurora
Colorado is his name his last name is
McLean why can't I remember his first
name but uh you know like things are
changing were like the help that there's
a new interim chief of police in Aurora
Colorado where he was murdered and this
is what she did so there was some cops
went to the vigil site right of where
you know there's a vigil for him and
they took a picture of one cop Chokin
another Cup and they emailed it to the
cops involved in the incident to cheered
him up like they were laughing as one
choked the other there's three cups and
it actually happened a few months after
the guy was killed right and she just
got the job and she felt this one cop
knew about the picture and he spoke to
the sergeant and the sergeant
came to her instead of the sergeant
brushing it under the rug and getting
this guy in trouble this officer in
trouble he actually brought it to the
new interim police chief and as she has
fired everybody involved everybody in
the photo there's three cops and the cop
one cop they showed it to he's like ha
ha she fired him for laughing and then
she held a press conference she
explained it so listen man there are
people who want to change things it's
gonna be but I was out there I want to
give you props because you're up against
some [ __ ] - tougher then races autumn
and it's tough that yay
you get blanketed with like all cops are
bad but that's what how black people
have to live - yeah no that's why that's
why I don't feel sorry for it I totally
get it
just say in the same way it's like we
have that in common yeah keep up the
fight with you thanks for the interim my
name is Vanessa I forgot our last name
the interim police chief in Aurora
Colorado for stepping up and firing cops
and putting yourself in the line of fire
against other cops and you know we keep
and every good cop out there man just
keep doing what you do well part of the
job and making it harder for you well
part of it to me is like that sounds
like somebody that's worried about
optics too along with trying to do the
right thing but just it's just a part I
watched her press conference she didn't
seem like an optics person oh no i'm
said but this is optics doing what she
did like like at a certain point at a
certain point I would think that the
mayor's governor's police chief's
somebody along the chain of command
people who are really in charge are
going like yo we got we we're getting a
lot of bad press because of this
behavior stop this like it this has
nothing to do with racism actually like
what I'm saying is like the
this person saying that could still be
racist they could be like I know you
don't like black people okay guys he
could be talking to the cops
I know some of y'all don't like black
people and I get it but yo stop killing
them on camera because we're getting a
bad rap like even that conversation I
feel like has never been said because
that guy that killed George Floyd man
the the the blatant disregard for he saw
he was being filmed he's looking at
people film him and the thought in his
head that I'm still gonna get away with
this is the chilling part that goes
above his head its above him it's it's
it's he's done so many things and had
just gotten away with it that he goes oh
I could probably get away with this too
and God knows what else he's gotten away
with yeah there's no accountability no
uncountable that's what I'm saying
there's no accountability so we do need
people like this police chief you're
talking about to be like hey let's make
ourselves accountable so window let me
just finish so when the bad ones do
something we now have a precedent that
hey that's just a bad one and we've
taken care of it in the past you know I
just don't think you can discredit like
a positive action like I'm honest cred
isn't it we're not we're not just
accepting this positive action as a
total revamp of the police were were
acknowledging this moment of honesty
right and pull it self policing and we
still want more of that you know what I
mean but yeah I know you know some cops
are being you know crying like [ __ ] has
been rough but this is going to continue
to be rough until it's good for
everybody including you because we want
to live a good free jazz
Justin uh-huh and and [ __ ] we're all
together in this like if the people
believe in the police they don't help
the police they'll make the police jobs
easier yeah is it yeah I'd like just a
few knuckleheads messing stuff up like
it but if we see you doing good this
goodwill goes a long way yeah I told her
I totally agree and you know I always I
always make reference to the movie
American Gangster you know you see
remember American Gangster with Russell
Crowe and Denzel Washington there's a
great there's a great scene in that
movie where denzel's caught he's in the
jail he's having a powwow with Russell
Crowe and Denzel is trying to buy him
and the guy who won't be bought and he's
like what do you want I turn on
everybody I'll give you all the Mafia I
give you everybody but Russell Crowe is
like he wanted the cops he wanted to
come because he wanted to clean it up he
knew he needed to clean house of all the
bad ones and it was going to be a rough
going but he knew after that they could
go in a better direction and I think
that we're at that crossroads right now
where you know there there is a
brotherhood those kind it's a
brotherhood I totally get it they are in
a tough position you know we should
acknowledge that too like it's so easy
for somebody to be like you should do
the right thing all the time yeah but
when like you're this is your job your
pension your family you gotta pay bills
and you know you're a part of this this
this family to this this work family who
is life and death you you understand why
some people they see no evil hear no
evil see no evil you know it's not right
but you have to understand you have to
have some empathy for the situation that
the the good cops are in you know yeah
but and I'm also is a video that came
out by a year or two ago and it was
black cops in New York City like in at a
news network
telling the people on news we are New
York City black cops were told to
enforce enforce quotas and in minority
neighborhoods and one of them even
recorded the chief telling him to do
that and they knew by doing this they
were going to be in the crosshairs of
all the cops like and they were inside
so if they can do it hey man everybody's
got a step up no but you know what you
easily are but here's the thing this is
what we need this is what I'm saying
what we know I I know what you're saying
but those black cops doing that that's
not the people we need to do that that's
a start and I'm glad that they did that
what we need is whoever the second
whoever is right next to that chief to
be like those are the people we need
it's like it's it's it's tough when like
it's tough because it's easy to brush
these people off I mean people have
power and influence when we start
reaching them and changing their minds
and making them speak out and making
them do the right thing then we're
really gonna see some change and I hope
that we putting the pressure on from the
bottom till we can fully enforce that so
we can put we can you know make positive
change that way if you understand what I
mean but we have the power influence
with people there's more of us
I agree it's I told I totally agree we
right we need a plan
somebody reputable to run it so that we
can all easily you know how you have
apps on your phone and your planner
right right and oh you have your banking
app in your son all I got to do is every
month do this slide this over here slide
so clear everything runs on automatic
pilot we need a plan like that
with the force of over a hundred million
people like electing the people will
make the right decisions for us because
we need people to fear feeding their
families that they won't be able to feed
their families unless they do the right
thing you know I mean so we don't need a
powerful like listen there's more of us
we just never there's only a few times
probably in our history when we've
mobilized yeah I know that's right
no you need like a like if there's a
up-and-coming person and they have the
vote of the people you know you know
that then what is the the person who is
entrenched and knows all the people
gonna do they're gonna have to move out
the way Martin Luther King didn't really
a lot of people you know he just started
his movement you know probably you have
Wednesday no a lot of people what you
hear you didn't even want to yeah so the
master question what do I do I got like
5% on my battery on this phone hmm so I
don't want to cut her off on you it just
popped up and said that oh well we could
just keep going until it cuts off but
you are you can't plug it in
let me see hole alright uh and we are
back we had some we had a technical
change you moved from duo now we all
zoom very professional very professional
hey I already had some technical
difficulties in the first place but here
we back our wadiyan and just to pick up
where we were actually I could just play
an Adele any matter um I don't even know
where we were but I do remember that you
had a point you wanted to make about
black lives matter I will just need like
some brains in the organization I'm not
saying there's no brains in it now but
just to just like any any like technical
platform we just need some brains to
organize to strategize and come up with
a plan so that maybe we don't even need
to protest like we could just take all
our resistance online and focus it on
the things online in a way so everybody
can participate who wants to participate
so that people can feel the force of the
numbers of people who want to do the
right thing and make life great for
everybody and also attract people who
can't go outside and March we don't
understand it to read more about it
online and like why we still this is not
the 60s why we still protesting in the
streets yeah it's just like hookers you
know like what hookers doing on the
street when you got the Internet it just
yeah exactly
you know like or like graffiti you know
you really like why you write not like
you think the vectors 'im no I can see
that no one cares about that there's an
other of their larger platforms yeah we
can we should like take the protests
into the future there's got to be an
online way to protest and to on all the
platforms maybe and send messages and
and just you know send like mass emails
to the cops and the DA's and to all the
people who need to be told that we on
their ass yeah like that like that like
that lady who killed her husband
Tiger king you know we need to put her
in charge of black lives matter she's a
great organizer yeah she gets [ __ ] done
you know yeah it's uh it's um you know
like I say I don't know I'm a little bit
more pessimistic right now just because
you know that III I feel like
the movement is losing steam with the
immediate online presence you know it's
like now people are back to like you
know promoting they're only fans and
people are back to you know it's like
it's not he'll be dope if somebody like
at the end of after they strip naked on
only fans of masturbate or they just do
it with a black lives matter banner in
the background just to show solidarity
so even while you're paying to what some
girl knew she's still like reminding you
black lives matter I saw some cops
defamed a black lives matter sign it's
like when you see that kind of stuff I
mean look there's still a people that
don't believe that they're that that
there's this hatred for black people or
hate you for any kind of movement like
this there's still people that think
that well that's not is it really like
that but then what is great is when we
catch people on video so they caught
these Kotla this like like a retired cop
or he's a current I don't know who he
was but he was slashing the black lives
matter sign and they get caught him on
video
it's like three guys doing that just
white guys you know you just go wow
really like that you know it's like like
the best thing to happen right now is
the videotapes you go back to like
Rodney King and like no phones no
nothing just somebody magically caught
just happened to be at the right place
the right time with an old-school video
camera and caught that horrific thing
and those cops by the way those cops got
off surprise you know so cut to now I
just if this dude that killed George
Floyd is acquitted it's impossible
he won't be you say that now because
this he because
just common sense is like like every cop
all over the nation has whether they are
on the right or the left has agreed that
this is a bad this was a bad thing and
they are not trying to do
even Trump didn't defend this cup you
know I don't normally people try to do
so and they saw what happened when
people protested and looted like every
company's like every corporation every
individuals like you have to convey this
guy is not worth having a phony trial
you know what I mean this is you know
what you say that but I know he's that
good you're saying so to go back to our
further point it's like money makes a
difference and this might be an example
where it finally is more important than
people's you know built-in racist
feelings yeah yeah it's like oh we can't
let this like even today I saw this
video of this husband and his wife they
were they were white and they were
painting the black labs only sign in the
street they were painting it over in
black right and the guy was yelling
racism doesn't exist and they're like
what about George Floyd well in that
case that was wrong even that guy and
his wife as they were arguing cuz the
bank I was like black people did the
white guy was like black people need to
stop resisting arrest and the guys like
yeah like George Floyd and he's like
well that was different
he wasn't resisting arrest that that
incident as as his wife paints over
black lives matter in black to like
erase it I know if you know it's it's
really funny how similar it is to how
people feel about wearing masks for the
kovat you know like like the other day I
got into a little and I didn't get into
a thing it just was bad timing
no you're fine dude stop moving it it's
perfect huh yeah don't worry about it I
am
so I tweeted out the other day that am i
a bad person that I feel satisfied when
people who downplay wearing masks and
covet get it
not knowing that Brittany shop just
tested positive and he's one of these
kind of people that has been hello at
all yeah has been blowing it off so then
like I got all these retweets and people
kept tagging him and I was like what the
[ __ ] going on so I had to hit him up
like yo bro this wasn't directed at you
but you know it's bad timing but it is
what it is you know anyway so it's like
it's so it's very similar like what
you're saying about like people the
people you know racist deniers you know
the cop that there are bad cops deniers
they're just like you know I like it so
I like I just I feel about the the
[ __ ] coronavirus I I don't want
anybody to die or anything like that but
man these people that are outwardly like
we don't want to wear masks and all this
stuff and then they get sick you just
kind of go alright well what the [ __ ] do
you think was gonna happen bro well well
just going back to black lives matter
before corona like here's one thing
black knives matter needs to do mm-hmm
like there's a mission statement on
their site that is disputable and the
term black lives matter is disputable so
when somebody says when a black person
or a person in support of black lives
matter says black lives matter and then
they say all lives matter you know like
that's a statement with somebody black
lives matter is a statement with
somebody can form a retort you know we
should say that black lives matter means
a group against racism
it's against racism or just everywhere -
on it you know so - yes miss it's
implied it's implied but people don't
say it should black lives matters better
- that's all that's all that that's all
that it really means then yeah so then
you can't say all lives matter we yeah
that or it changed the definition to
like you know we're against racism you
know when two people that brand these
things they do they do a terrible job
it's like defund the police yeah it's
such a terrible statement like it
doesn't really encapsulate what they was
really trying to say what the whole
point of it is it makes people sound
like it makes it sound like oh we're
gonna let there's gonna be no police and
saying that's not what it is and so
whoever the but then it's like that kind
of stuff catches fire on the internet
it's just like me - it was the same kind
of thing somebody somebody said that
then it was like oh we'll use that all
right that's our hashtag we're gonna use
it let's move on with it I think that's
what happened with black lives matter
yeah it needs to be more thought out so
yeah black lives matter - would actually
be perfect like I don't even know the
response you could come up with to that
and that doesn't make you sound racist
you need to come up with a phrase where
if somebody's against it they sound more
racist than if they say all lives matter
as that is just beyond the shadow of
that's why I was like back lives matter
- like you said or just say we're
against racism you know - black people
and if you dispute that there's no way
you can't look racist so you can't
dispute it unless you're just saying
[ __ ] it I'm racist which is fine that's
what we want to know because dude I got
this idiot on Instagram I'm not even
gonna say his name or anything just some
idiot who keeps he's white and he keeps
sending me like the sort of like all
lives matter sentiment type stuff you
know he's the kind of guy that sends you
messages like you know look why are you
quiet about this black person that got
killed by black people or why aren't you
talking about given the incarceration
rate why don't you talk it's like it's
like those it's like that kind of white
person it brings up those kind of facts
and like which to me is like those
things are separate and it's something
we can also talk about but racism
towards black people is still real you
know but let me just finish one thing
like the thing about the conflict like
when I hear people say George Floyd was
a criminal my response to that is so
that's their job like the cops job is to
deal with criminals and to deal with
dangerous situations and that's what
they're trained to deal with so that we
that's why we have them again they're
not dealing with nuns and Penn and
whatever that it's not it's not the Boy
Scouts that they're going to arrest if
they're going to arrest in a dangerous
situation
we're hope that they're gonna do it
justly bigger they're gonna use their
training to de-escalate that they're not
gonna try to like do their own justice
that their own they're not the judge and
jury that's their [ __ ] job so I don't
care if the guys are criminal I don't
care what that person is doing we we
want these people to be better than the
criminals that is the whole point right
yeah you're a cop you're not to judge in
a jury
there's a system for that years it
doesn't matter if he's a criminal plus
that cop has more infractions on his
police record
then George Floyd has crimes committed
that's another thing I know and when
somebody tells you what about
black-on-black crime there are
statistics statistics that you can send
them about white on white crime you know
they act as it just answer back Oh what
about whiter my crime eighty-five
percent of murders of white people are
caused by white people that's a high as
number mo'fucker murder who you live
next to so that's gonna happen
regardless for black people and that's
gonna happen regardless for white people
so shut that down number one and a part
of the reason I don't know why why
people aren't murder and why people but
a part of the reason why black people
are murdering black people because they
have lived in
economically depressed areas have been
forced to live in economically depressed
areas they are pit against each other by
a systemic racist system that causes you
know a high rate of desperation and lack
of money and people do things to get
that money plus arch by the way has been
flooded with drugs by you-know-who in
one of our great presidents you know to
destroy it so that they could get money
to fund you know a terrorist group in a
South American country just look at the
iran-contra and then the when the person
brings up the incarceration rate it's
just just tell them to watch the
documentary the Thirteenth Amendment on
Netflix but you but do you know the
other thing too about that what you're
saying is I think minority is especially
black people you have poverty okay
poverty alone just put poverty and
that's gonna cause some of these issues
because that's what happens in the poor
white neighborhoods just look look at
cop yeah you know if you watch cops
there's not a lot of black people on
cops it's a lot of dumb white people
doing dumb white people [ __ ] ain't no
dumb why people neighborhoods cuz
there's poverty they're just have like
trailer parks or just as trailer parks
and urban ghettos are the same you know
what I mean but then in the urban ghetto
you talk then on top of that you have to
deal with racism you know but like so
like that's reason that that's that's
the thing right there - I mean there's
more white people on welfare than
anybody because they're the largest
number in a population there's a lot of
poor white people and I just don't know
how hopefully they get out a vote
realized that they need to make a change
like I'm not a political or anything
like that but it's like this seems to be
like a really important election but I
don't even know what's going on with
that I mean I think even the people that
were fully supportive of Trump are
getting sick and they're like yo dude
I'm sick and ain't a wall you know so
like oh [ __ ] I do it nuttiest promises
like you know like how can you have a
straight face and support you know
what's happening
right now because the the right has done
a wonderful job of demon demonizing
anybody on the left so even if the
somebody on the left has a great idea
they'll be like you're the left this is
like everything from the left there is a
conspiracy for it you know what I mean
and you know they've talked about like
liberals in Hollywood mean child
molesters like nobody would ever listen
to a group of people who they consider
child molesters I did they come up with
a way to frame the left to look a
certain way so that no matter what
anybody from the left says if you're on
the right and you're rooting for the
right you know you just dismiss what
they say automatically yeah
hire Snoop Dogg so you did he said I've
never voted before but I'm voting this
time no no yeah you might he might have
he might have a donee got priors yeah
man this has been I don't know dude it's
just been a it's been a tough time I
know the first time we talked in the
beginning of when the corona broke out
you know I know you were talking about
being depressed and you know it's like
so now we're on month three I think it
is right it's it's like month three
since Mars longer yeah March March April
May June and then I was starting July
yeah this is like because it was half of
March and now we're an almost in half of
July so yeah it's like three and a half
months feels like longer it does feel
like longer feel yeah and it's and I I
still don't like the uncertainty of
what's happening like I don't know like
what are what are where are we what are
we doing like you know what I mean like
what's you know there's just no there's
no like game plan I just you know you
turn on the TV and it's just it's just
terrible news all the time yeah I mean
that's how the news is though it's
always terrible it's devised on both
sides left or right to split the country
like we just need somebody listen man
you just need somebody with a plan if
somebody comes up with a plan and
they're sincere and they're honest and
people catch wind of it like you know I
got talking to anybody out there
who's got a good ass plan like it
probably won't even matter who's the
president because I think the Democratic
Party does not care I think the
Republican Party does not care like the
Democratic Party they just pretend to
care but I have no intention of fixing
things or doing the right thing you
could tell by the candidate they have
served up to us and you know so so we
lose no matter who we vote for yeah I
don't even know where like I haven't
even they where is he he's been making
speeches but uh somebody posts something
today and he was reading it and he was
read Biden was reading it because he
knows if he goes off the cuff he's gonna
say something crazy but the way he was
reading it it was like you know the
worst reader in your class in school
yeah
yeah and they're just trying to like
they're almost it's the best day of a
read but it's still bad compared
everybody like he was so yeah that's
that's what he's that's what our
potential Democratic candidate our
Democratic candidate sounded like today
I was in I saw some of the results from
one of those primaries from like a month
or so ago and like like Bernie Bernie
still getting votes oh yeah so I don't
know how like if Biden was smart he
would just get all those people he
should just get like Elizabeth Warren to
be his vice president Bernie be uh you
know Speaker of the House get booty
check in there and have him you be
something you know what I mean I just
don't I don't understand loyalty to a
party neither do i well oil tea to a
party ruins everything then what do you
need that it's like if you all you need
is a cardboard cutout cuz yeah you know
because what if you have to follow the
party lines then what is the point of
even doing anything
yeah just vote for the person from each
party that is actually a legit candidate
you know you don't have
this gives your democrat you don't have
to fool democrat just because you're
republican you could switch if there's
an assemblyman or council person or a DA
or just somebody who's like seems on the
up-and-up and things were not Kanye yes
honey you know this is not my theory but
it sounds solid like Kanye's Astaire
he's a friend of Trump and he's just
might run because he hasn't filed yet he
just might run to take away votes from
Biden to help Trump so you know I was
gonna vote for I'm not voting for the
guy who's less slavery was a choice yeah
yeah but the only see to me the way if
you're on the left and you don't want
Trump to win to me the only way Trump
doesn't win is if like somebody on the
Republican Party runs against him or
somebody is some independent like you
know that's how Clinton won Clinton
wasn't gonna win without what's-his-face
Ross Perot you know without Ross Perot
Clinton loses it loses bad you know so
same thing with this it's like you know
what's that guy of Mitt Romney he should
have just been like he already he's
already the one guy who stepped up and
been like I don't agree with our
president he's a Republican so you know
like that needs to come up and be like
running take away all he needs to do is
take away like 15 percent of the vote
yeah I would vote for Mitt Romney across
the board I would root for him to win
the whole thing
Oh over Trump and Biden yeah he's he's
more legit than both of them like yeah
yeah he seems like he seems more legit
of a person and presidential and any one
of those two guys yeah oh man I just
like again I'm just trying to like not
be depressed and trying to like you know
just between like I haven't seen my mom
now in three-and-a-half over three and a
half months cuz I just don't want to go
over there I don't want to risk it you
know and then my mom you call yeah I
talk to her all the time like July 4th
was her birthday yeah but you know at
least she she understood because I think
my stepdad was
you know it's your birthday but that
kind of thing you know so you know it's
just like just just dealing with that
it's just man yes I know a lot of people
out there they probably feeling what
they're feeling you know you got like I
say you have anxiety or depression and
it's like listen I don't they call dr.
Phil a quack and you know he's one of
these people that was pushing like we
need to open the economy and all this
stuff because he was saying like the the
depression is gonna be just as
detrimental to society as the
coronavirus itself and I agree but I'm
not saying that we should just open
everything up but I agree that this is
gonna have long lasting effects on our
psyche of the what is hat what is
happening right now
suicides up like a lot
yeah divorce suicide there's just a lot
a lot of like I know
so people that you're feeling what
you're feeling out there not I do
recommend people you know they have a
lot of online besides psychology things
now you know talk to someone I think you
should share how you feel because a lot
especially the people around you you
should really try to share how you feel
so they could be a source of comfort and
support and also so they don't think
it's them because that's what kind of
happens you know it just happens where
you're like around people you're close
to then you're acting a certain way and
anything what's that because of me and
then now they're getting there
completely but all they need to be told
is like no I'm just feeling it because
of this and then people will commiserate
be like oh you know what I'm feeling
this - then maybe we realize we're all
feeling something and then maybe we can
like help each other stay positive and
move forward but I know how hard it is
out there that's why I'm saying this
right now and watch some comedy videos
[ __ ] like that yeah man
when do when do you when do you I mean I
asked I mean I already probably already
know your answer but like cuz I'll just
say my answer cuz I was gonna say what
do you think we're gonna actually be
doing comedy or when do we think we're
gonna that comments gonna be back to
normal and to me the only way is like we
have to root for the doctors and
scientists that mean this stall the only
way is like it has to be gone it has to
be like we're Coronas nothing it's just
like the polio or something it's the
only way
and I don't know when that's gonna
happen yeah I don't know I don't have no
answer I have to [ __ ] me talked about I
don't have them answer no no none of it
probably made any sense I'm just I'm
just you know I got a talk just to just
to try to clear out the clutter yeah in
my mind and like the zeroing in on the
you know get closer to what the right
thing is so I was talking about this is
I was talking to my science buddy I had
him on my podcast but NASA guy he's like
actually he's actually doing really good
he's applying to be an astronaut right
now and he's it's like a really tough he
wants to get out of here yeah he has a
really tough process you know he's gonna
leave Earth huh yeah he's about to
graduate and actually that SpaceX
mission he had some parts some parts
that he worked on were on that spaceship
so he's like really you know he's really
excited but he was telling me that you
know like well how did he say it it was
something about if 65 percent of the
population were to get the corona virus
that's when we'll see a real downslide
because at that point more people have
gotten it I think the herd immunity will
kick in but we're at 3% right now so to
get to 65% would take like eight years
so it's like are we gonna live like this
no no they don't find a virus a vaccine
for it by then so you know hopefully
like but this is not like I just don't
think this is a thing you could fix in
three and a half months yeah you know
this is you know like what we keep
thinking they could keep but they keep
changing you know it's like all of a
sudden it's like okay we're gonna
weather these phases that they had they
were gonna open up the economy and now
they're like well well we [ __ ] up it's
like like a Florida and all these kind
of places that they were just like put
two middle fingers up now they're just
like okay so now your hospitals are
flooded what are you gonna do right
yeah exactly Wow and then numbers are
going up but they're testing more - yeah
yeah that's a part of it you know yeah
like I watched videos or read comments
from both sides and it's like I the
right [ __ ] up the left [ __ ] up both
sides of politicizing things right and
hate it and then even if something's
right it's if the left has a good
suggestion nobody on the right wants to
hear because they think it's a political
ploy and there's somebody on the left
has something that makes sense nobody on
the right ones to hear it and vice versa
so because why that like it's just
saying before it's like people are on
teams [ __ ] these teams man like just get
the best out of both you know what I
mean I know it's like you know they play
your shoes but like you're the same
restaurant every day like you're in
Vegas if the buffet at the Rio is good
fine but you're not gonna go there every
day you're gonna try out the bar fill
you up to win and and if you like the
one at the win and the one at the Rio
you're gonna like today at the win they
have crabs so let's go here and get the
crab and then let's go to the to the
real on Wednesday because they got
lobsters like we got a buffet this
should stop sticking to some dumb team
because they're both corrupt and that's
funny it's like you know that you talk
about politicizing I just thought it was
so weird like how Trump you know he you
could tell he was you know you he was
trying to get the religious crowd the
evangelists and all these people I was
like okay we gonna open up these
churches and then like that then they
traced it back to like a big outbreak is
from people going to church and so then
it's like oh now we got a backtrack on
that instead of just doing the right
thing like the right thing would have
been like we need to close this down you
know let's go to zoom guys but it's like
just the the I I hate that there's a I
think the president should be president
for six years and an asset you know no
reelection it's just six years and then
you get a new guy
noburo yeah that's what I want the
reelection process is ridiculous it just
it takes away from there's like a year
and a half or you they're not even
really being the president anymore
they're just trying to get reelected
it's right but but also they're forced
to do a good job in the first year in
the first four years because they want
to get reelected so they just need that
stimulation now you have to do a good
job or people right now you know you did
need some incentive okay maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe but I am I am looking
for I didn't realize I just saw I
haven't seen one of those soccer games I
was thinking I can't wait for the NBA to
come back I doubt that the NFL is gonna
be able to even start and finish their
season I think that they're being
ridiculous I think these sports shows
that are on every day and they keep
talking about the NFL that's gonna
happen I just think they're they're just
doing it because they need something to
talk about but when the season comes and
they're like no we're not gonna play cuz
football I don't see football working
without like unless they film it
differently it's gonna be ridiculous
maybe they can put just that the
uniforms could be PPE you know I'm
saying like like whatever protective
gear they using the hospital they can
like kind of make their uniforms like
like that change their uniforms
completely have more focus in spacesuits
with Cleveland Brown on the back just
like the lady or those big like sumo
outfits and it just you know it's like
there's so many people on an NFL
sideline there's 53 players you're
talking about all the coaches a lot of
the coaches are old a lot of the coaches
are like 50 and up you know so they have
to worry about you know their their
their health - it's not just like even
in the NBA I heard all this guy Ric
Bucher talking about this you know like
lobbies and an NBA coaches they're in
their 70s yeah you know so you know you
have to you have to worry about more
than just these like premier athletes
who are getting in and they're getting
over it like a war once one NBA player
dies the whole [ __ ] oh shut down but
right now there just ain't like it's
Ezekiel Elliott he's a
symptomatic he got it he's like I feel
this in that and you know he leaves gum
corn chain for 14 days and then he'll be
fine but you know and so every one of
them would see that and they go oh well
I'm like him you know the NBA has a good
chance like NBA does I think you have a
better chance than anyone else but I
still talk they have less players in
soccer so they have a better chance of
like everybody yeah but I think soccer
is fine because no two players are only
you you're only occasionally near
another player like I always oh you're
being marked constantly I know I know
that people make walls you be more
constantly but so far the lease are
continuing like the German league
started up and they finished their
season and you know I mean is pretty
discipline that's a good stereotype that
they have discipline there's so much
money in sports there's so much money
they're just like well what a last thing
though do you think that there is a
point where people are just gonna be
like hey if you get sick you get sick
this is our new reality corners are part
of our life so if you get sick [ __ ] it
you know but I'm going to the beach or
I'm going you know people are at that
point yeah people have been at that
point for months and that's how some
people have been living since the
beginning of coronavirus and they're
like [ __ ] it like I'd rather go back
people make choices I rather go back to
my regular life then be in quarantine
I'll live a quarantine life so yeah
people are there they're not waiting for
the government's permission
I just wish our business was able to
like start to more I guess they are I
think a lot of productions and stuff
from moving forward like I got an
audition I got a day I got a read
forward stuff like that so I don't know
we'll see I guess I guess things are
starting to you know move forward but
I'm just I miss it man I just miss you
yeah yeah I miss my life i missed the
things we were doing I'm I just I missed
that constant interaction uh within the
stand-up community I miss just all that
stuff I really do it depresses me
yeah I don't even know if I miss it that
much you know I don't I don't know maybe
I was tired and I needed to rest
you know like somebody asked me the
other day do you do you miss it
and then as I should I've been working
since I was like 17
like not in comedy but just work and
that work went to school and then school
and work and then after school you know
it's just comedy and regular work until
I could support myself yeah just through
comedy and then just kept six only 68
years later that's fine so I like like
I'm in the house there is you know what
there is upside like I get what you
saying there's like I've lost weight I'm
down like 20 pounds I got this new look
you know I you know my relationship is
that it like at a really high point and
though you know I'm you know I'm gaming
now and you know I just
so yeah I'm trying to make the best of
it but you know just talking about it on
this platform is just to say yeah I I
feel you people out there if you feel a
depressed I also feel depressed but at
the same time I am finding some silver
linings and things too and so I should
talk about those things too like I say
relationship is good I'm trying to keep
I've turned I'm healthier than I've ever
been you know in recent years and you
know so I'm trying to see like when I'm
trying to prepare myself so when we do
come back it's a whole new me all right
that's though and you know yeah people
who need help I hope you reach out and
try to get some help yeah I don't know
the places maybe maybe under the the you
know in your description of the podcast
if you have some links and stuff yeah
maybe I'll leave your side and I'll look
for some way there's like a lot you know
it's just you don't put the devil or
nothing like that you know you search
for like they had there there actually
are some really affordable even give us
some of the caldera pee therapy things
out there I don't have no sponsors for
it but I still do that yeah just give me
something to click on you know some way
they could go to get more information or
get about places or options that they
have
you know yeah like some people are gonna
thrive some people are gonna struggle
and go up and down like this moments
I've had when I was I yeah man like I
gotta get out the house or this is not
you know great you know but for the most
part you know I just but I think that's
just how I am anyway luckily you know I
don't take that for granted that right I
can laugh through something like bad
times for some reason yeah you know so
you know I'm just blessed I'm like that
I don't you know so and you know just
try to grow through this and overall I
think when this whole thing is over
this will automatically I think this
would just be a better country period
yeah as we're all going through this
thing we all have time to think and we
are reacting in a way to things that we
normally didn't or wouldn't react in
that way before this and there are
opposition factors and that's fine
they're getting to emote and there are
views clashing more than ever but we're
gonna need that you know not everybody's
gonna be on the same side but you know
just you know I'm gonna be positive and
hope that we all figure this out and by
the end of this thing will be like [ __ ]
Thank You kovat you know oh yeah I
totally agree that's like that's a good
place to end on we've been it's been
over an hour and I appreciate you coming
on once again you know I'll reach back
out again and they're like a month or so
you know I'm gonna see if I'm still
alive I know yeah check and see how he's
doing
have you actually gotten tested by the
way let's end on that of you did you go
get two just to check your for yourself
I'm I'm Mike this week I said it last
week but I undo it
I could go to Dodger Stadium like I
might go to my next hell if I go to next
hell for to do stuff and they have like
I might get the what is what is it the
what does that test not to it's the
antibody test yeah I might go get the
antibody test to see if I've had cuz I
kind of feel like I kind of feel like
wasteful and I both gotta I think she
had it when she was in New York we went
to Fashion Week and she got really sick
and it was right before March you know
it's like like right at the end there
when people were talking about it but
nobody knew what the [ __ ] it was so
we'll see but anyway this has been Ian
Edwards like I say my good buddy the
funny two talented writer comedian oh
did you want all right good all
all-around good person I got all this
information down below I try to find a
couple of links down there too for some
songs you get some help and you know
stay up stay positive and I'll talk to
you soon brother and I appreciate you
doing it thanks man one loving and good
[ __ ] thanks Amy oh yeah